This UCSD-TV program is presented by University
of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up with the latest programs.
Also, make sure to check out and subscribe
to our YouYube original channel UCTV Prime
available only on YouTube.
Here at the University of San Diego, we have
taken our designation as an Ashoka Changemaker
Campus very seriously.
Change is a creative process that can be applied
in business, politics and peacemaking.
And our honored guest this evening, Senator
George J. Mitch...
Mitchell, has worked for change in all of
those arenas.
His bio is in your program.
Years in service of many kinds you'll see
described there: military service in the U.S.
Army Counter-intelligence Corps, legal service
in the Justice Department as a U.S. attorney
and a district judge in Maine, and political
service in the Senate and as a diplomat.
Senator Mitchell alternated that service with
business experience and private law practice
as chairman of the board of the Walt Disney
Company, a member of the board of his beloved
Boston Red Sox, and as a director of several
other companies.
In each of those positions, Senator Mitchell
was not focused on the status quo, but on
changing laws, on changing organizations,
on changing this world and on changing his
own country.
Senator Mitchell knows that change takes time.
It was 14 years ago that he brokered an agreement
between Catholics and Protestants in Northern
Ireland and the Good Friday peace accords
were signed.
Then, just this summer while visiting Belfast,
Queen Elizabeth shook hands with former IRA
chief Martin McGuiness, now a top official
in Northern Ireland.
This was a man who had been an avowed enemy
of the British Empire, and in fact a representative
of a paramilitary group that in 1979 was responsible
for the death of the Queen’s cousin.
Yet this moving reconciliation, a symbol of
putting violence in the past to create a better
future, is the ultimate goal of every peace
negotiation — more than just a ceasefire
or a signed peace agreement or even a power-sharing
agreement.
Change takes time and change takes vision,
like the vision that Senator Mitchell has
for bringing people together in the most difficult
of circumstances.
And now it is our honor to listen and hear
and share with Senator George J. Mitchell.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[Applause]
Thank you very much uh...
Julie, for that generous introduction.
And thank you, ladies and gentlemen, for your
warm reception, for your presence here this
evening.
Uh... to the dean, the new dean, thank you
for inviting me and for being such a gracious
host.
It’s a real pleasure for me to be here at
the University of San Diego and in particular
here at the Joan Kroc Institute for Peace
& Justice.
Uh...
I...
I welcome the opportunity to visit the university
because I know it was started by the Sisters
of Mercy.
I started my education... my life in education
at a parochial school in a small town in Maine,
and I was taught by the Ursuline Sisters.
And I can remember to this moment the discipline
that they instilled in me.
[Laughter] And I have had a high regard for
nuns of all kinds ever since then.
And so it’s a special pleasure to be here
in that regard.
I uh... want to repeat my thanks to Julie
for that generous introduction.
Now, I entered the Senate under unusual circumstances.
I was serving as a federal district judge
in my home state of Maine when one of Maine’s
senators, Ed Muskey, was appointed secretary
of state, creating a vacancy in the Senate.
Since it was the middle of the year, the Senate
was in session.
The governor, on the day the vacancy was announced,
said that he was gonna move quickly because
he didn’t want Maine to be underrepresented
in the Senate, and he would hold a press conference
the following Monday at noon at the state
capitol to announce his choice to succeed
Senator Muskey and fill out his term.
So there was a lot of speculation in Maine.
We had a former governor, a former senator.
My name was barely mentioned.
I'd just been appointed a federal judge the
year before.
It’s a lifetime appointment.
So I went to bed early that Sunday night — we
go to bed early in Maine — [Laughter] Uh
and uh... like everyone else, wondering what
the governor was going to do the next day.
About 11 o’clock that night the phone rang.
It was the governor calling.
He said, “I’d like you to come down to
the state capitol at noon tomorrow so I can
announce that I’m going to appoint you to
the Senate.”
I said, “Well gee, governor, this is a big
surprise."
I said, "This is a big decision uh...
I gotta think about it.
I’ve got to call my family, talk to some
friends, think it over.”
He said, “I’ll give you one hour.”
[Laughter] I protested that that was inadequate.
He said, “Well, look.
You call me at midnight and say you’re not
going to do it, I got 12 hours to find someone
else, most of them in the middle of the night.
So you can’t take more than an hour.”
I said, “OK, I’ll call you back in an
hour.”
I hung up.
I called my three older brothers.
I grew up in a small town in Maine, and I
had three older brothers who were very famous
athletes, not just in our little town, not
even just in our state; my brothers made all-New
England in college basketball and they were
very well-known.
And then I came along and I was not as good
as my brothers.
In fact, I was not as good as anybody else’s
brothers.
[Laughter] And so very early in my lifebecame
known around our small town as Johnny Mitchell’s
kid brother, the one who isn’t any good.
[Laughter] As you might expect, I developed
a massive inferiority complex and a highly
competitive attitude toward my brothers.
So when I called them that night ostensibly
to seek their advice, [Laughter] there was
a note of triumphalism in my voice.
[Laughter]Everybody here who's got a brother
raise your hand.
[Laughter] So you know what I'm talking about.
So I said to them, “Listen, guys.
The governor just called me and he wants to
appoint me to the Senate.
What do you guys think about that?”
Well, the responses were predictably negative.
Very negative.
My brother Johnny said, "Look," he said, "Everybody
knows you’re a born loser."
[Laughter] He said, "You couldn’t possibly
win a state-wide election.
None of us can understand how you got to be
a federal judge, so you better stay where
you are.”
My older brother, he... he thinks he’s somewhat
of an intellectual and he likes to use the
Socratic method; he... he makes his points
by asking questions.
So he said, “Well, now," he said, "let’s
look at this from the standpoint of the people
of Maine.
[Laughter] Aren’t they entitled to have
a qualified person representing them [Laughter]
in the Senate?
And isn’t it obvious that you’re not one
of them?”
Well, after a few minutes of this I’d had
enough.
I hung up.
I called the governor.
I said, “Governor, I don’t need an hour.
I’ve already received all the reassurance
I need [Laughter] of my ability to perform
this job.”
So I went down the next day to the state capitol.
The governor made the announcement.
I flew to Washington that night and I arrived
at National Airport about 5 o’clock and
I had nothing planned that evening.
The swearing in was scheduled for the next
morning.
Literally on a whim when... when I get into
a taxi, on the spur of the moment I decided
I’ll go up to the Senate, I'll find and
introduce myself to the Senate majority leader,
then Senator Byrd (it could not possibly have
entered my mind that one day soon I would
become the Senate majority leader), and...
just kinda get the lay of the land.
So I went up, a clerk took me into the Senate
— the Senate was then in session debating
a bill — and introduced me to Senator Byrd.
And he's very busy — if any of you have
ever seen the Senate in session when there
is debate and there's a lot of senators milling
around and Senator Byrd somehow got the impression
when the clerk introduced me that I was there
to be sworn in.
So he said, “OK," he said, "we’re kind
of busy but we’ll swear you in.”
I protested, I said, “No, no, no," I said,
"This... this is set for tomorrow morning,”
I said, "I had in my mind that all three networks
are probably reserving time [Laughter] for
tomorrow morning."
I thought...
I thought for sure it would be on the front
page of the New York Times.
I said, "We can’t upset those guys."
Byrd said, “Listen, young man.
We’re very busy here.
I said I’ll swear you in and I will swear
you in right now.”
So he interrupted the debate, swore me in
and it took less than 10 seconds.
Nobody but he and I and the guy who swore
me in know what's going on.
Even senators standing six feet away and in
conversation were unaware that they had been
joined by me.
Uh... and then and then the... so it was a
huge disillusionment for me.
I was expecting something rather grand and
uh... uh... and then they resume the proceedings
and almost immediately a vote occurred.
I hold the all-time history, all-time record
in American history, for those of you interested
in political trivia, for having cast a vote
the in shortest time after becoming a senator:
[Laughter] two minutes.
[Laughter] The first of many informed judgments
I made on your behalf, on behalf of the people
of Maine.
[Laughter]Well then Byrd said to me, “You
know, you’re kind of in luck.
Filibusters don’t happen too often around
here.”
That was then.
Not the case now.
He said uh.., “There is one coming up in
a little while.
Why don’t you hang around, see how things
work around here.”
So I said, "OK."
I went, took my seat in the back of the chambers,
number 100 — as far back in the corner as
you can get.
And uh... after a while everybody else had
left and one senator came in.
He... he got the floor.
He got up and said, “I want to say a few
words.”
And he spoke for six hours.
About halfway through I began to realize that
I wasn’t learning anything here.
And the thought crossed my mind that maybe
I ought to leave, but of course, I had no
place to go.
I didn't know what the protocol was and he
must have sensed it so he... after a while
he came over and talked to me.
He stood right in front of me and he kinda
pointed his finger.
[Laughter] Six hours this went on.
And then - I don’t know how many of you
have been in the capitol when a vote occurs
- the bells ring, the lights flash.
It’s a way of telling House and Senate members
how much time they've got to get to a vote.
They call the vote on a procedural matter;
that’s how you keep these filibusters going.
The lights flashed and the bells rang.
I didn’t know what was going on.
In pour the other 98 senators.
They all voted on this procedural matter,
and then they all left.
And I, not knowing any better, stayed there.
Pretty soon another guy came in and he talked
to me for six hours.
[Laughter] This went on all night.
I thought, this being a senator is not all
it’s cracked up to be.
[Laughter] And after a while I was tired,
I was hungry.
I went up to a clerk who was standing by the
door at the side of the chamber and I said,
“Excuse me, I’m new here.”
He said, “Senator, that’s obvious to everyone.”
[Laughter] I said, “I’m hungry, I’m
tired."
I said, "Where did all these guys go?
Well I’m here.
I thought I was doing the nation’s business,
working hard.
I’m the only one here."
He said, "I...
I...
I said, "Tell me where they go."
He said, “I will not only tell you, I will
show you.”
And he took me around behind the Senate chamber
into a room smaller than this, where there
were a whole bunch of narrow, canvas folding
cots set up — of the type you see in emergency
shelters.
And there, lying there in their clothes, were
a bunch of old white guys [Laughter] snoring
away.
Oh my God... talk about disillusionment!
[Laughter] It was crowded, there were no aisles.
He said, “Senator, there’s an empty cot
in the middle.
You better grab that one.”
I looked and I had to climb over other senators
to get there.
The first guy I encountered was Ted Kennedy.
Ted is not, was not a slight fellow and at
that moment he looked to me like Mount Everest
in a suit.
And I worried that I might disturb him.
So I used all the athletic skills that my
brothers say I don’t have.
I got over him and then I looked on the next
cot.
Lying on his back, snoring loudly, was Senator
Jesse Helms of North Carolina.
I’d only been in the Senate one day, but
I was aware of Senator Helms’ role as a
stalwart defender of heterosexual rights.
So I was really nervous.
[Laughter] I thought, what would be the consequence
if I lost my balance and fell right on top
of him,[Laughter] my first day in the Senate?
So I tiptoed over him and I got to this empty
cot and I lay down and I...
I really was disappointed.
I thought, what a mistake I’ve made.
Just a few hours ago I was a federal judge.
[Laughter] I wore a robe.
People got up when I entered the room, they
sat down.
[Laughter] They got up when I left the room.
Now I...
I was lying here with these guys.
And I began to feel sorry for myself.
And as I wallowed in self-pity, I...
I rolled over on this little cot and I look
right next to me, literally inches away, into
the face of Senator John Warner of Virginia.
At that time, he was married to Elizabeth
Taylor.
[Laughter] And I looked at him and I thought,
who am I to feel sorry for myself?
[Laughter] I said...
[laughs] I said, I, really, I thought, here’s
a guy who could be home legally in bed with
Elizabeth Taylor and he’s spending the night
with me.
[Laughter] And I’m feeling sorry for myself?
Well, I realized then what we all know but
we tend to forget, is that no matter how bad
off you’ve got it, there’s always someone
who’s got it worse.
And you can go through life complaining about
things or feeling sorry for yourself, or you
can try to do something about them.
And that was a good lesson for me because
I did try to do something and uh... enjoyed
myself in the Senate a great deal.
Tonight, I’m not going to talk about the
Senate.
I was asked to speak about my experiences
in Northern Ireland and the Middle East.
And I’ll do that.
Then I want to say a few words in conclusion
about our own country uh... and then I’ll
be glad to take your questions uh... in conclusion.
I spent five years in Northern Ireland, coming
and going and working there and I chaired
three separate sets of discussions.
The principal negotiation lasted about two
years.
It was for the most part extremely difficult,
very discouraging, with little progress.
There had been ceasefires established, but
they were routinely violated.
There was regular and periodic assassinations,
bombing.
Two of the men who were delegates to the talks
were assassinated during the talks.
Several others had been involved in the conflict.
Some had been wounded badly, some had served
lengthy prison terms for their activities
and violence.
We hit what I thought was rock bottom in December
of 1997, which was about 18 months after we
started.
Two days after Christmas a prominent Protestant
paramilitary leader was assassinated in prison
by a group of Catholic prisoners.
That touched off a tit-for-tat series of assassinations
on both sides.
Emotions rose dramatically, and the prospect
of success declined.
In an effort to try to change the direction,
the governments of Britain and Northern Ireland
uh... and Ireland moved the talks from Northern
Ireland to London, and then from London to
Dublin.
But the change of venue did no good.
The rancor increased.
And on the flight back to New York from Dublin
after a week there, uh...
I concluded that the process was spiraling
toward failure and the likelihood of a resumption
of violence on a scale previously unimaginable
would result.
And so in desperation I formed a plan to establish
an early, firm and unbreakable deadline, after
which the process would be over one way or
the other.
And after some consultations, I established
midnight April 9th as the deadline, after
which I told them I’m leaving and we’ll
either have an agreement or we’ll have failure
and war.
The last two weeks were uh... round-the-clock
negotiations.
On the last night, uh...
Prime Ministers Tony Blair and Bertie Ahern
came.
President Clinton stayed up all night in the
White House on the phone.
I was in constant communication with him and
them.
And we finally succeeded in getting an agreement
uh... on the afternoon of Good Friday uh...
of 1998.
I, with two colleagues who assisted me, was
responsible for drafting the document which
became the peace agreement.
As I did so I had in mind many objectives,
two principal ones.
One was that it had to be their agreement,
not my agreement.
On the very first day that the negotiations
began, I said to the delegates to the peace
conference, “I do not come with an American
plan.
There is no Clinton proposal.
There is no Mitchell proposal.
Any agreement that you reach will be yours.”
Over the two years of negotiations, collectively
they spoke millions of words to me and they
buried me in documents: legal briefs and memoranda
and petitions and papers and statements.
And so, when I drafted the agreement I made
certain that every word, literally every single
word, had been spoken or written by one of
them.
And when I presented it to them I said orally
what I've just said, and I had a cover letter
that said to them the same thing.
That was of critical importance.
It is...
No one is going to subscribe to a document
in which they must by definition make concessions
if they feel it is imposed on them, unless
you have an all-out war and you have a total
winner and a total loser.
But in conflict resolution, short of that
there has to be ownership by the parties and
I was acutely aware that whatever happened,
I was leaving and going back to America.
They were staying.
Their lives were the ones at risk and at stake.
It was critical therefore that they decided
their futures.
The second objective I had was to make certain
that in that document was something for both
sides.
I tried to envision each of the political
leaders on both sides of that divide meeting
with their strongest and most ardent supporters,
and include in that agreement something that
they could hold up and say, “This is what
I got: A, B and C.” Now of course, I had
to give them a little something to get an
agreement, but it has to be a win-win situation.
Short, as I’ve said, of total conflict and
total victory and defeat, there has to be
a prospect which enables political leaders,
and particularly political leaders in democratic
societies, to justify their willingness to
enter into an agreement uh to prevail.
And it did.
They knew, as we all knew, that under the
terms established by the two governments for
the negotiations, any agreement reached would
not take effect unless approvedin a referendum
by the public in Northern Ireland and in the
Republic of Ireland.
Both had to approve independently before it
would take effect so the politicians who were
in there making the agreement were gonna have
to defend it and explain it to their publics.
And they did, and it was approved by a wide
margin in the referendum in both Northern
Ireland and the Republic.
Now, what did it take to get there?
A lot, and I can’t describe every aspect
of it, but let me make just a few points that
I think contributed to it.
And they all come under the heading of common
sense.
Patience and perseverance: you have to stick
with it.
In conflict resolution you can’t take the
first no for an answer, or the second no or
the 10th no or the 50th no.
I don’t intend or mean to be critical of
the press, but every day you see the reporters
wanting to set up failure.
A negotiation begins - there's one going on
in Washington right now - but they didn’t
get an agreement the first meeting they had
so it’s a failure.
Almost every day over the five-year period
that I was there, I was asked by reporters,
“When are you gonna leave?
When are you going home because you failed?"
In a sense they were right.
If your objective is to get a peace agreement,
until you actually get it you have failed
to do so.
But there’s a difference between a final
failure and working towards success even as
you experience setbacks.
And there has to be perseverance.
Secondly, this is so simple, you have to treat
everyone with respect — even, indeed I would
argue especially, those with whom you disagree.
None of us have problems agreeing with people
of like mind.
We’re all humans and one of the things we’ve
learned now from the amazing scientific discoveries
that are being made, particularly about the
human body and especially the brain, is that
our receptors for information that agrees
with our preconceived notions are that big
and very acutely sensitive.
Our sensors that receive information that
disagrees with our prior beliefs are that
big and not very sensitive to things coming
in.
Every one of us suffers from that.
And politicians in life-or-death negotiations
to end conflict, to end death and destruction,
have especially acute sensors to that with
which they agree and very little that they
don’t agree with.
And so you have to listen very hard.
You have to try very hard to open your receptors
especially to people who disagree with you.
And I think that’s true not just in conflict
resolutions between nations, but in political
negotiations within a country such as ours.
And you always have to have the humility to
recognize that on occasion you may be wrong
and the person who disagrees with you may
be right.
It takes a person of self-confidence and self-knowledge
to make that kind of approach to issues, and
to genuinely practice those, but that’s
what’s needed in conflict resolution situations.
You have to give everyone their say.
When I first went there, indeed on the first
day, I said to them, “I’m product of the
U.S. Senate.
We have the rule of unlimited debate.
I’ve actually listened to a 16-hour debate,
to an 18-hour discussion, to a 12-hour speech.
Nothing you guys can say or do," I said, "that
will faze me.”
Did I regret that [Laughter] years later.
Of course when I said that I had no idea how
long this was gonna go on.
So there I sat day after day, month after
month, year after year, listening for hours
and hours and hours.
But what I learned is that first off, if you
really do listen to people sometimes they
make sense when you really think about it
from their perspective.
And secondly, it is a necessary condition
to getting their agreement to something that
they don’t like that their view has been
heard and genuinely considered.
And every one of us, everyone who's a parent,
everyone who's married, everyone who has any
kind of a personal relationship knows the
difference between someone who is genuinely
listening and someone who is going through
the motions of listening.
And genuinely listening is hard work, but
it has to be done.
And finally I’ll say, you need political
leaders with courage.
The political leaders of Northern Ireland
were ordinary men and women.
You had one of them here last year, a terrific
woman, Monica McWilliams, a very close friend
of mine.
And she is not unique; an ordinary person
like every one of us here, placed in a position
of responsibility and authority and they rose
to the occasion.
It’s very fashionable in our society and
others to denigrate, to ridicule, to demean
and insult politicians, and Lord knows they
earn it and deserve it some of the time.
But the fact of the matter is, people can
and do rise to the occasion with courage,
with judgment, and do the right thing and
that’s what they did in Northern Ireland.
A... a lot of people talk about Clinton, about
me, about Blair, about others.
The people who really did this in Northern
Ireland were the political leaders and the
public in Northern Ireland who... who understood
the consequences of failure would mean a new
outbreak of violence, to the savagery and
a destructive toll that far exceeded anything
that had occurred before.
And that’s what we need in other crises
as well.
Well, I thought it was tough in Northern Ireland,
and it was - five years, five very tough years.
But a few months ago I spoke at a dinner of
an Irish American group in Queens, New York
City.
About 1,000 Irishmen there.
And I said to them, “I’m about to say
something that I never dreamed that I would
believe or say.
And it is that after three years in the Middle
East dealing with the Israelis and the Palestinians,
the Irish were a bunch of patsies [Laughter]
but uh... they were really easy.”
Now the Middle East let me talk about that.
The conflict between the Israelis and Palestinians
is historic, complex, very difficult.
So I cannot in a few moments or even in a
few hours give it full justice.
Uh... what I am about to say is necessarily
uh... a summary that won’t touch on every
aspect of the conflict, but describes some
of my experience and my conclusions uh from
the time I spent there.
The upheavals now occurring across the Arab
world, especially in Egypt and Syria, have
create... created anxiety and uncertainty
among both Israelis and Palestinians, making
progress in reserv... resolving that conflict
more difficult than ever.
But even before the Arab Spring, the conflict
has gone on for so long, has had such destructive
effects, the level of mistrust and hostility
is so high, that many there and elsewhere
regard it as incapable of solution.
But the pursuit of peace there is so important
to them and to us that I think it demands
our maximum effort, whatever the difficulties
or setbacks.
The key to resolution is very easy to state,
but extraordinarily difficult to achieve.
It is the mutual commitment of both Israelis
and Palestinians, and the active participation
of the United States government and the many
other governments and entities that want to
help.
Commitment to the task of reconciling the
Palestinian goal of a viable, contiguous,
sovereign and independent state based on the
1967 lines with agreed swaps of land, with
the Israeli goal of a Jewish state with secure,
recognized and defensible borders.
Security is what the Israelis don’t have
for their people, even though they have a
highly successful state.
In early nine... in early 2009, President
George W. Bush went to Jerusalem, where he
said in a speech, and I quote, “The point
of departure for permanent status negotiations
is clear: There should be an end to the occupation
that began in 1967.
The agreement must establish Palestine as
a home line... homeland for the Palestinian
people, just as Israel is the homeland for
the Jewish people.
These negotiations must ensure that Israel
has secure, recognized and defensible borders.
And they must ensure that the state of Palestine
is viable, contiguous, sovereign and independent.
It is vital,” Bush said, “that each side
understands that satisfying the other’s
fundamental objectives is a key to a successful
agreement.
Security for Israel, and viability for the
Palestinian state are in the mutual interest
of both parties.”
That's the end of Bush's statement.When he
took office in 2009, President Obama publicly
reaffirmed that policy.
And it seemed then, in early 2009, that the
culture of peace so carefully nurtured during
the Oslo process had largely dissipated and
had been replaced by a sense of futility,
of despair, of the inevitability of conflict.
The first Gaza military operation, as you
will recall, had just ended four days before
Obama took office.
Israelis had an election campaign on, the
Palestinians were deeply divided, and as a
result very few people believed that there
was any chance even to get negotiations started,
let alone conclude negotiations successfully.
And unfortunately, that remains the case today
nearly four years later despite an intense
effort.
A solution cannot be imposed externally.
The parties themselves must negotiate directly,
with the active and sustained support of the
United States.
Both recognize that, both acknowledge it publicly
and privately.
Now, to succeed they will both have to engage
in compromise and be flexible.
But most of all it will take political leadership
by all concerned, leaders who are willing
to take some risks for peace.
I still believe that this conflict can and
will be ended, in part because I believe that
the pain from negotiating an agreement — which
will be substantial — will however be much
less than the pain that both will endure if
there is no agreement.
If the conflict continues, both Israelis and
Palestinians face a dangerous and uncertain
future that includes of course the possibility
of renewed violence, which could expand in
unexpected ways to enflame the region.
This is after all a region in which there
are several intersecting conflicts occurring
at the same time, and any one could trigger
a spread to others like a wildfire out of
control.
There are many other dangers to both.
I can’t go into them all but I’ll briefly
summarize the principal ones.
For the Israelis I’ll mention just two.
The first challenge they face is demographics.
There are now about 5-and-3/4 million Jews
living in the area between the Jordan River
and the Mediterranean Sea.
In that same space there are about 5-and-1/4
million Arabs, including Israeli Arabs, Palestinians
in the West Bank and Gaza.
The Arab birthrate overall is much higher.
They don’t agree on much, but both agree
that within just a few years — and I’m
talking about a very few years — the Arabs
will be in a majority.
And if there is not by then a two-state solution,
the people of Israel will have to choose between
being a Jewish state or a democratic state.
It will not be possible for them to be both.
It cannot occur if there is not a two-state
solution.
This is not much discussed in this country
but widely discussed in Israel, most recently
and forcefully by Ehud Barak, the former prime
minister and now the defense minister who
has said repeatedly that this is a painful
choice that Israel should not have to make.
Their second challenge is technology.
To keep out suicide bombers Israel built an
enormous wall.
But the real threat as we all know now doesn’t
come from suicide bombers.
It comes from rockets.
Hamas still has thousands of them even after
the recent operation.
They’re crude, most of them homemade, lacking
in guidance, lacking in destructive power,
but they still create fear and anxiety.
And can anyone doubt that over time they will
achieve an increase in both numbers and quality
of the arsenal?
They’ve stated it as an objective following
the ceasefire.
On Israel’s border, Hezbollah has tens of
thousands of rockets.
The public estimates in Israel are between
30,000 and 50,000.
They’re somewhat more effective, and although
limited in range they're engaged in an effort
to upgrade their arsenal.
And finally and most threateningly, Iran now
has rockets that can reach Israel when launched
from Iran itself.
All of the discussion has been about nuclear
weapons.
That’s a very serious problem.
But aside from that, Iran has made a huge
technological advance in moving from liquid-fueled
to solid-fueled rockets; far easier to operate,
far easier to conceal, farmore difficult for
Israel or us to target.
The Iranian rockets don’t yet have the precision
our... ours do — that is, to strike a specific
building or military target.
But they can come close and if launched they
could cause enormous destruction and death
in Israel’s cities.
The United States is fully committed to Israel’s
security.
And that commitment is firm, unshakeable and
will be kept.
To honor it we’ve provided enormous financial
and military support to Israel, most recently
in the development of the effective anti-missile
system that protected them from many of the
lockets... rockets launched by Hamas.
But it is unknown, because it’s never before
occurred in human history, what would happen
if simultaneously thousands and thousands
of rockets were launched from all three locations.
And so, Israel’s very existence then could
be threatened.
The Palestinians also face serious problems,
obviously and especially the indefinite continuation
of an occupation under which they do not have
the right or the dignity that comes with the
right of self-governance.
In 1947 the United Nations proposed a plan
to partition the area and create two states.
Israel accepted it, the Arabs rejected it.
The first of several wars began, all of them
won by an increasingly strong Israel.Every
sensible Arab leader today would gladly accept
the 1947 plan if it were still on the table.
But it is not on the table and it will never
again be on the table because the circumstances
have so dramatically changed.
And since then, the plans offered to the Palestinians
have been less attractive than the ’47 plan,
and they’ve rejected them all.
But as I told Chairman Arafat directly during
my first tour of duty in the region, and as
I told President Abbas directly during my
most recent tour of duty, there is no evidence,
none whatsoever, to suggest that the options
available to the Palestinians are going to
get better in the future.
So what they’ve got to do is to reach the
common sense conclusion that they’ve got
to sit down, participate and stay in direct
negotiations, and get the best deal they can:
less than what they want, no doubt from their
perspective it will be imperfect and unfair,
but they’ve got to bring the occupation
to an end and they’ve got to create their
own state.
And they can then build on it as Israel has
done, and as the Palestinians can do as they're
demonstrating now under the outstanding leadership
of their prime minister, Salam Fayyad, who
has laid the foundation by building the institutions
needed for a viable, independent state.
Unfortunately, that state-building effort
cannot be sustained in the absence of progress
on the political side.
They’re inextricably linked, and so there
has to be progress on both in order to be
progress on either.
It’s a daunting challenge especially to
build trust where mistrust exists not only
between political leaders but between the
public in both societies.
But they must find a way to renew hope, and
we must do all we can to help them despite
the difficulties, because it is not only in
their interest, it is in our interest as well.
My last point this evening involves our country,
where I believe our power and our principles
are mutually enhancing and must be firmly
bound together.
The American Declaration of Independence was
a powerful statement of the right of free
people to self-governance.
The first 10 Amendments to the Constitution,
what we call the Bill of Rights, is a concise
and eloquent statement of the right of the
individual to be free from oppression by government.
Most concepts of democracy in our world today
rest heavily on these two principles, and
in this dangerous world they can be maintained
and defended only if we are strong and prepared.
The American Revolution was not initially
a rejection of British principles.
It was triggered by what the colonists believed
was the failure of the British government
to apply those principles equally to them.
A perceived gap between our ideals and our
actions now is a factor in the hostility of
others to our country and to Western democracy.
The triumph of democracy and the fall of communism
was the signal event of the 20th century.
As we move into the 21st century, the power
and the ideals of the United States are influential,
indeed ascendant, around the world.
There've been many dominant military and economic
powers throughout history, and that role brings
enormous benefit and many problems.
In this era of instant communication especially,
every grievance in the world — no matter
how local, whether real or imagined — leads
to both a request for assistance from us and
resentment to us, whether we grant the assistance
or not.
Obviously, most people want to be on the side
of the strong.
But for too many people in our country and
outside of our country, power increasingly
is perceived to be the primary or for some
the exclusive basis of American influence
in the world.
I think there’s much more involved.
Power's clearly important, and we must be
prepared to use it — including military
force — when necessary and appropriate.
A strong economy and a strong military power
are essential to our security, our freedom,
our prosperity.
But power must be deployed not as an alternative
to our ideals, but in service to our ideals,
for it is American ideals that is and always
has been the primary basis of American influence
in the world.
They’re not easily summarized, but surely
they include the sovereignty of the people,
the primacy of individual liberty, an independent
judiciary, the rule of law applied equally
to all citizens and crucially to the government
itself, and opportunity for every member of
society.
Because of those ideals, I believe that the
United States was a great nation long before
it was a great military or economic power.
This was a great nation the day the Constitution
was ratified.
Four million people clinging to the Atlantic
seaboard became instantly one of the most
influential countries in the world because
of our ideals.
There were no wars then.
We had a very tiny army and a tiny navy.
We didn’t have missiles.
But we had the power of our ideals.
They guided us through the early turbulent
years; through the greatest crisis in our
history, the Civil War; through the difficulties
of the 20th century; and they have to guide
us now through the different but still difficult
challenges of the 21st century.
I’ll close with one more personal story
uh... to make the important point of opportunity.
When I was a federal judge I had great power,
and I have to confess I really loved that
part of the job.
[Laughter] The only job I ever had where I
had any power.
When I was Senate majority leader all you
can do is ask people to do things that they
should be doing without being asked.
[Laughter] But when I was a federal judge
every order I ever gave was carried out to
the letter, and that was great.
But what I really enjoyed was when I presided
over what are called naturalization ceremonies.
They’re citizenship ceremonies.
A group of people who'd gone through the required
procedures gathered before me in a federal
courtroom in Maine.
And there, by the power vested in me under
our constitutional law, I administered to
them the oath of allegiance to the United
States and I made them Americans.
It was always highly emotional for me because
my mother was an immigrant, my father the
orphaned son of immigrants.
Neither had any education.
My mother could not read or write.
She worked the nightshift in a textile mill
in Maine for 40 years.
My father was a janitor at a local school.
But because of their efforts, and more importantly,
because of the openness of American society,
all of their children got the education they
were denied — and I, their son, became the
majority leader of the United States Senate.
After every one of these ceremonies I met
personally with each of the new Americans,
individually or in family groups.
I asked them where they came from, how they
came, why they came.
They talked about their hopes, their dreams,
their fears.
Their answers and comments were as different
as their countries of origin, but through
them there were some common themes andwere
best summarized by a young Asian man, who
when I asked him, “Why did you come here?”
and he replied in very slow and broken English,
“I came,” he said, “because in America,
everybody has a chance.”
Think about that.
A young man who had been an American for 10
minutes, who could barely speak English, was
able to sum up the meaning of our country
in a single sentence.
America is freedom and opportunity.
That’s what it is for all of us, and they
are linked.
There will not be freedom for all if there
is only opportunity for some.
I believe that in this great country in which
we are so fortunate to be part of — the
most free, the most open, the most just society
in all of human history, despite its many
imperfections.
And I believe that here no one should be guaranteed
success, but everyone should have a fair chance
to succeed, to go as high and as far as their
talent, their willingness to work, their willingness
to take risks, will carry them.
Our con... our challenge, each of us here,
is to so conduct ourselves that 50 years from
now, 100 years from now, people all over the
world will still want to come here for the
same reason that young Asian man wanted to
come: because they will believe in America
there is a chance for everyone.
I spoke in Europe recently and there’s a
certain amount of hostility, some envy, about
the United States.
And one guy got up and read, pleased with
himself, an article that said China’s gross
domestic product is going to equal that of
the United States in 2048, and China’s into
uh...
China's on the rise and America’s in decline.
“What do you think about that, Senator Mitchell?”
I said, “Well, first off, if in fact their
gross domestic product equals ours in 2048,
that means on a per capita basis we’re four
times as large as them.
It’s the per capita GDP that really matters,
so I’m not too worried about that.
But secondly,” I said, “I might ask you
a question in response to your question.
Aside from a few North Koreans struggling
to... to... get out of the concentration camp
they call a country, trying to get into China,
aside from that, have you ever heard or read
of anyone risking their lives, crossing the
ocean or crossing the desert or climbing a
fence or burrowing a tunnel, to get into China?”
[Laughter]Have any of you ever heard of that?
Last year, 500,000 Chinese left their country.
Even with the restrictive out-migration rules
they have there, a large number of them want
to come here.
Now they don’t come here because they think
we’ve got it... a good Patriot missile.
Not one person's ever cited that as a reason
to risk their life.
They come here because they know here they’ve
got a chance.
They’ve got a chance to get what human beings
want everywhere: a decent job, good care for
their kids, a good education to get their
kids off to a good start in life.
Isn’t that what we all want?
No matter the color of our skins, no matter
what ethnic group we come from, no matter
what religion we practice, no matter where
we are — that’s the basic universal desire.
And what we've gotta do is to make certain
that a 100 years from now people around the
world still want that because it will be true.
Now we do know this: It’s still an aspiration
here.
We’re not perfect.
And it is not true that every single American
has equal opportunity.
Working at that is something that we’ve
been doing for 225 years and we have to keep
at it.
Don’t ever forget that great as were the
men who wrote the Constitution, and they were
great in every sense, they were constrained
by the society in which they lived and learned.
And so the Constitution, which we revere in
its initial form, did not consider a black
person to be a whole person.
And it restricted the right to vote to only
adult white men who owned property.
It took 75 years and the bloodiest civil war
in our history to extend the right to vote
to persons who were not white.
It took another 60 years to extend the vote
to women.
Look at all the women in the audience here.
Can you imagine, 60 years of ferocious political
battle to extend the right to women?
It’s unimaginable to us now.
That was the case.
And then it took another half-century until
we passed the American with Disabilities Act
to extend to persons with disabilities the
right to live a full, free and independent
life in our open society.
And we’re going through the same issue right
now with respect to sexual orientation.
And there'll be other issues in the future.
But what our history tells us is a people
optimistic, hopeful, successful, willing to
confront error, willing to change, willing
to make things better for everyone — that’s
freedom and that’s opportunity, and that’s
America.
Thank you all very much.
It was a great pleasure to be here.
[Applause]